good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is David Thoreau and I'm the
president of the independent Institute
here in Oakland California I want to
welcome you all to our independent
Policy Forum program this evening as
many of you know we hold events like
this on a monthly basis approximately
featuring many top scholars and policy
experts and authors of important new
books and tonight is no exception our
program today is entitled why freedom
matters more than ever and our speaker
today is the economist and author David
Henderson who is author of a very
important new book which I hope that
everyone will be getting called the joy
of freedom and economist Odyssey as many
of you know the independent Institute is
a non-profit public policy research
organization we sponsor studies by
different scholars that result in books
and we published a journal called the
independent reviews edited by Robert
Higgs and we end up covering a huge
number of major issues our forum this
evening is intended to engage audiences
in many of these issues we're
particularly grateful that Robert
Mondavi is kind enough to donate the
wine for these programs and I also want
to encourage all of you who are
interested in public policy issues to
visit our website at independent org
I want to particularly welcome our
viewers from c-span today and on our
website you can find information not
only about our publication and events
and media programs and so much more but
also information on our homepage
specifically about many of the issues
involved in the current war on terrorism
in the aftermath of September 11th
firstly everyone is recognized that the
specific individuals responsible for the
mass murders have to be brought to
justice and in doing so everyone is
seeking not only justice but security
but not as an end in itself we seek
security to enjoy the blessings of
liberty the American legacy of Liberty
and we believe that we must achieve
security in a matter consistent with a
diverse and open society individual
liberty and the rule of law however
continuing to deny the obvious fact that
the horrific events of 9/11 are related
to US policy in the Mideast is I think
of a Mis gotten sense of what is
happening in the last few months since
9/11 we've seen an interesting series of
events we've seen a stampede of
lobbyists using the cover of terrorism
to extract corporate welfare for the
airlines for the insurance industry for
agriculture and a host of other special
interests a new office of homeland
security has been established now I
thought that the Department of Defense
was supposed to be protecting the
homeland
now if they're not the question is what
is the department of defense doing in
addition we've recently seen the passage
of what some would consider to be a
rather Orwellian USA PATRIOT Act which
is given police and intelligence
agencies the opportunity to do searches
and intercept information from all
Americans the presidential Records Act
has been overridden by President Bush
the President signed into power a new
series of secret military tribunals to
try non-us citizens attorney general
Ashcroft further wants to authorize the
FBI to go after any religious and
political organization in the United
States that might be in suspect we've
nationalized airport security the alarm
moves to restore the draft legalize the
use of torture by the police and
interrogating suspects Institute a
national ID card and the list goes on
and on clearly these are measures that
before 9/11 none of us would have not
considered none of us would have
considered to be even feasible as a
discussion in a serious manner history
teaches that periods of crisis
especially during wartime can often
create even greater problems in addition
to the crisis itself and the crises that
that developed as a result are caused in
many respects by the crowding out of
civil society by an expanding government
one of our senior fellows is the
Economist Robert Higgs who I mentioned
who is also the author of this book it's
called crisis and Leviathan and it's a
book that discusses many of these kinds
of matters
the question that we wanted to address
is in overcoming the new threat of
terrorism and then just generally
looking at the many social and economic
problems that people face must freedom
be restricted is freedom during wartime
and recession as important as during
peacetime and prosperity what is the
relevance of individual individual
choice in free markets to such matters
as safety education health the
environment community culture and much
more David Henderson is associate
professor of economics at the Naval
Postgraduate School he's also a research
fellow at the Hoover Institution at
Stanford University he received his PhD
in economics from UCLA he's taught
economics at Santa Clara University st.
Louis University and the University of
Rochester and he served a senior
economist with the President's Council
of Economic Advisors he's also the
editor of an important book called the
Fortune encyclopedia of economics which
I also strongly encourage everyone to
get it's a it's a wonderful book
especially for anyone interested in
learning about economics his condi study
studies have appeared in many top
journals he's a very prolific author in
the popular press with his pieces having
appeared in the New York Times
fortune Los Angeles Times Chicago
Tribune and many other publications
including various high tech magazines
such as the red herring he's testified
before numerous government agencies were
very pleased to have David with us and
after his talk will be happy to field
any questions that you might have so
David
thank you David and thank you
well David laid out a lot of the threats
to Liberty and I will get to those but I
want to talk about some good things for
a while and in fact as you can tell the
joy of freedom
I really think freedom is joyous I don't
want to start by telling you something
that I just learned about a year or two
ago and in fact this is the first
paragraph of my book for the last two
centuries economics has been called the
dismal science the person who coined the
phrase was the British anti-capitalist
author Thomas Carlyle
now I'd always thought that what he had
in mind was Thomas Malthus Malthus the
population economist who said that
population growth would outstrip
agricultural output thus causing massive
mass starvation wrong economics is a
dismal science wrote Carlyle because the
free market economists of his time who
dominated economics in the 19th century
strongly opposed slavery economics is
dismal because economists don't like
slavery interesting view of dismal well
for me economics has always been the
joyous science because it says that a
good deal of freedom is necessary for
prosperity which means not only can you
have freedom but also you get prosperity
as a bonus so that's always been the
draw of me for on me for economics of
economics there's a chapter in my book
titled the joy of capitalism and when I
was working on my just the final little
draft of that chapter one Sunday morning
about 5:00 a.m. the title of the book
suddenly occurred to me the joy of
freedom that's what the whole book is
about and I lead off that chapter with a
quote from a friend of mine who died
about nine years ago that some of you in
the audience may know a man named Roy
childs and he said this and I remember
writing it down and fortunately I wrote
the date down he said this in 1988 and
this is how I led that chapter off
ultimately capitalism will be socialism
because capitalism is more fun a year
later the Berlin Wall fell now I started
out as in as an undergrad in mathematics
and I was reading a lot of economics on
the side I read on Rand and I really
liked a lot of what I earn Rand had to
say and then my libertarian friends were
a couple years older led me to people
like Milton Friedman Murray Rothbard
Ludwig von Mises Henry Hazlitt and I was
learning a lot but one of my calculus
professors said well when do we get we
get on these arguments and after I
here's one an interesting thing I
noticed and I'm part of this is to say
why I'm talking so much about economics
tonight even though I know it's been
pitched as a thing about civil liberties
I'm gonna get to those but but economics
is really relevant here because what I
found in almost every discussion I was
ever in in those days and cents is that
when people start arguing about their
principles within one or two or at most
three rounds of discussion it turns to
practice the big problem people had with
freedom was does it work and I would be
arguing if my my calculus professors one
particular person and I would kind of
back him into a corner and he said well
look I admit you backed me into a corner
but I'm just a humble mathematician I
bet you the economist could take you on
why don't you go over to the Economics
Department note them and I thought you
know you're right maybe I maybe I'm
missing something here
so I took economics in my last year of
college and we had a book by that many
of you might be familiar with by a man
named Paul Samuelson I'm I'm free Canada
and we had the Canadian version which
was Samuelson and Anthony Scott was the
Canadian author for the Canadian content
part and it didn't cover any of the
issues that libertarians were interested
in but it didn't really cover any issues
that liberals were interested in in
other words it wasn't covering the stuff
everyone was arguing about so I kind of
gave up on the idea of
in economics and then something happened
in my last semester of college
our libertarian group had a man from the
University of Chicago come to our school
named Harold dem sets and dem sets kind
of opened my eyes in two days of three
talks over two days to what economics
had to say and I have a chapter in the
book titled hooked on economics and I
talked about some of the things I
learned from him one of the things was
that free markets make discrimination on
racial grounds costly free markets make
it costly to discriminate against people
on any grounds other than their
productivity because if you refuse to
hire people who are productive you're
gonna miss out on good people similar if
you're a landlord and you refuse to hire
to rent to someone who's the wrong color
you're gonna miss out on potentially
good tenants now it doesn't mean that
people won't discriminate what it means
is when you discriminate you pay a cost
and the higher the cost the less
discrimination
whereas government regulations often
make the cost of terminating on racial
grounds zero and the example dem sets
gave was that in American cities during
World War two governments imposed rent
controls a rent control keeps the price
below what the market price would have
been so at the lower price people want
to rent more apartments but landlords
want to remember apartments there they
don't have as much an incentive to rent
them out and so you have a shortage when
you have a shortage the cost of
discriminating is effectively zero
because you've got lots of people to
choose from and what he found by going
through Chicago Tribune ads over the war
period was as the shortage got worse the
percentage of ads in the Chicago Tribune
that said this is restricted restricted
was the code word in those days that
percentage went up now there's another
really great example of this in a recent
movie a movie in the 90s it's one of my
favorite movies titled Schindler's List
who here's seen Schindler's List
think about what happened there think of
the first half of the movie what
Schindler did he cared about one thing
he cared about making money that's all
he cared about he had no concern for
these people he would be employed but he
noticed that the German War Office was
charging out Jews at five units an hour
and I've forgotten the unit's and as and
non-jewish poles at seven units an hour
and he said aha
I can make money hiring Jews and that's
what he did now he didn't pay them he
paid the money to the German Reich
office which is by the way the way
Castro does it in Cuba when when people
hired these workers at high wages they
pay the wages to Castro who then gives a
tiny pittance to the workers in Cuba but
something happened halfway through the
movie and some of the critics and I
talked about this in the book some of
the critics described it as puzzling
contradictory this man is strange he
started to like the people he worked
with boy is that strange he didn't have
a Marxist cardboard character view of
humans Wow and that's kind of relevant
nowadays I want to point out a couple
things that happened in September 11th
that got a lot of press for the first
couple days and then it just kind of
disappeared because we've heard that the
heroes are firemen and policemen and
medical people and they were they here
they were heroes but they weren't the
heroes they were some of the heroes
there were other euros too I have a
friend who has a friend who ran a small
business in the World Trade Center when
the airplane hit the building first
thing he did this owner of this business
was stood up and said everyone out he
didn't say hey let's get twenty more
minutes of work and then let's get out
the point is that we often here and
again this is kind of the propaganda
about capitalism the propaganda about
markets that employers are cruel
employers don't care about people and
yet
if you are employer you know this if
you've known employers you know this
what's one of the toughest things
employers what's one of the things
employers hate most about their job
firing people and and that shouldn't be
surprising and I have a chapter talking
about this a greater length about how
markets breed virtue because see one of
the things that the kind of the latest
hit on capitalism is the following it's
true that markets produced the goods
it's true that capitalism works to
produce the goods by the way that's a
recent admission if you look at stam
uses 1985 edition you'll find him saying
in there that the Soviet Union is gonna
really produce it's producing well it's
gonna grow well because socialism works
by put you know forcing labor and
diverting resources where they're most
needed and so on and so so it's a recent
admission now in fact as soon as the
Wall fell I found out something
interesting I noticed a lot of liberal
economists saying you know isn't it
great that capitalism works and isn't it
great that socialism fell and I'm I
won't there was a part of me that wanted
to write an article saying well but
remember what you were saying a few
years ago there's another part that said
no except them I mean if they if they're
now saying that that's great we've got
them on our side let's go but here's
back to what I was saying they were
people said sure capitalism produces the
goods but it's short on virtue well I've
got a chapter in there titled market
virtues and community in which I lay out
how actually markets do create virtue
because one of the biggest virtues in
life is accountability and that's what
markets create you don't make it very
far if you're not accountable you and a
good comparison is compare FedEx and the
u.s. US Postal Service compare FedEx and
what do they call the overnight thing
that's kind of overnight postal Express
when I hired a research assistant when I
was working in my unfortunate cyclopædia
I gave her a couple rules the first day
and the first rule was don't use postal
Express
she said don't mail things overnight
Ines oh no no no don't use postal
Express mail them overnight and the
point is why the difference because with
Federal Express there's someone
accountable there's someone who in
economics jargon is called the residual
claimant there's someone who's
responsible whose assets or wealth or
well-being are on the line in the post
office if I have a problem and I worked
my way up my chain and I don't ever
bother working my way up the chain I get
all the way to the top William Henderson
no relation and he can't do anything
even if he wants to his hands are tied
so there's a real accountability in day
to day activity and it's so present and
here's the problem it's so present that
we forget to take account of it it's so
present that we often aren't even aware
of it how does that relate to some of
the things going on now well look at the
issue of airport security and in fact
well let's go there and then I want to
go to another point about airport
security Jay Leno put it best the other
night he said we've got now federal
employees are gonna be running airport
security so not only are they
incompetent but you can't fire them how
is that going to work how is that gonna
get us more airport security no one laid
out how in fact the Democrats pitched it
as this is so important we want the
federal government to run it the obvious
comeback for Bush would have been to
give the Federal Express postal Express
overnight US postal Express the type
comparison and he didn't do it and so
the Democrats won by pitching the issue
in a way that you know it's important if
it is important well then of course the
government should run it but there was
no comeback and that means the people
who are going to be running and think
about the difference first of all I want
to note something that has been under
noted you know everyone's been pointing
to the with Argand bright that's one of
the security firms and other firms that
are running that have been running
airport security and how they're paying
low wages and have high turnover and
it's a move up to work it to Cinnabon
and so on
but interestingly the thing that
happened in September 11th wasn't due to
anyone making a mistake the things that
got through were completely legal so yes
you could point to incompetence many
times there were people who got guns
through in the past but the point is
what they didn't did was completely
consistent with the rules they were
supposed to follow so it was the rules
that were wrong it wasn't the enforcers
and so what do we get and by the way
notice that the airline's who were
hiring these people had some trade off
they had to make between security and
speed security and convenience if the
airline hasn't you too much you miss
your flight and then they're in trouble
but if the federal government is running
it and you miss your flight
tough too bad that's that that's not
their concern and that's what we're
gonna be facing fairly soon
also notice by the way we're gonna be
facing that from the same organization
that still thinks it's important to tell
us how to fasten seatbelt I remember
there used to be an airline around here
called Morris Air which was bought out
later by Southwest I believe I remember
flying Morris air from from San Jose to
Phoenix I believe and the woman coming
on and saying for those of you who don't
know how to fasten seatbelt which means
those of you haven't been in a car since
all about 1962 that's the point they
have these crazy rules or the other one
has anyone unknown to you as you carry
something have you been away from your
bag
you know all these things these are the
things they think of is important I
don't see how we've solved anything I
think we've added a huge problem
moreover I was giving a talk on this in
Washington about six weeks ago and I was
telling some of these same stories and
someone Chris DeMuth the head of the
American Enterprise Institute told story
he said that Delta Airlines about two
days after September 11th
had noticed their bookings going way
down and we're seeing their airline at
risk and came up with a plan ends on
their planes and they had a whole
advertising to start thinking through an
advertising campaign you know fly with
us and you're safe and they called up
the FAA and said you know we want
permission to have retired FBI agents
carrying guns and the FAA said no you
can't so not only are they not going to
do a good job of providing security
they're actively preventing airlines
from providing security interestingly by
the way Europe has many private airports
Maggie Thatcher D nationalized seventeen
of them and there's a whole lot more of
a private role in security in one of the
things that I learned from well I put
together in my second chapter a list of
ten what I came to call pillars of
economic wisdom and at the start of
every course I always lay out these
pillars and go through various examples
of them and I won't go through all of
them here but there's one that I want to
point out and that is what's sometimes
called the law of unintended
consequences when you do something in
order to achieve a certain end you may
achieve that end you also necessarily
achieve other ends some of which might
not be your purpose and sometimes it's
so perverse that you achieve the
opposite of your end and we see that
with many government policies the
example I give in the in the book is the
is how Ralph Nader essentially created
the SUV Ralph Nader and I gotta give
credit to where it's dude Ralph Nader
and Gerald Ford Gerald Ford pushed
something called her signed into law
something called the cafe law corporate
average fuel economy that required that
auto companies achieve a certain number
of miles per gallon on their whole fleet
year and had a separate small lower
requirement for trucks that was what
economists call a binding constraint in
other words
it kept that average higher than the
market would have yielded especially
when it was past a time of very high oil
prices and then of course oil prices
started dropping so people wanted the
bigger cars this was one of my issues
during but I should go back Nixon gets
some credit here too
why did we have this big problem it was
because there were these price controls
that Nixon imposed on August 5th 1955 71
that caused shortages throughout the
economy when the OPEC price increase hit
and I'll fall of 1973 prices were not
allowed to go up at the retail level so
we had shortages of gasoline people
sometimes murdering to get gas there
were a number of killings at the time
and that was and so people were trying
to get more gas than was available you
quit the government could have responded
by just getting rid of price controls
they didn't do that instead they said
look at how wasteful people are huh
we're keeping the price artificially low
and people are acting as if we're
keeping the prices artificially low what
pigs and in fact some of Carter's
officials any cars this was later on
called us energy pigs well so if they're
going to do that then the next call is
for all kinds of regulations to prevent
us from using so much fuel and the cafe
regulations were part of it well this
was one of my issues when I was the
energy economist of the Council of
Economic Advisers under Reagan in the
early night early 1980s cafe laws and I
want to get rid of them what I noticed
was that station wagons were
disappearing and I wrote an article
banned it's obvious why because they get
less fuel economy and they were bringing
down the average too much I wrote an
article about this after I left the
council you're a lot more restricted in
what you can write about when you're
there which is one of the big negatives
of the job you forget how to how to
write well no you learn how to write
quickly a memos but you forget how to
write to a general audience so I wrote
an article that's laying out how the
station wagon would was disappearing and
would disappear and also pointing out
that it also explained why small truck
sales were rising dramatically because
this small truck average is 21
the car average was twenty seven point
five miles per gallon what I did not
anticipate but should have is the
creativity of Detroit because Detroit
said hmm we want something that fits as
a truck but kind of looks like a station
wagon
thus the SUV now how does Ralph Nader
get in this well I have a little segment
in the book where I had I lay out I had
an hour and a half long interview with
Ralph Nader that was really about an
hour and 25-minute long argument after
the niceties and when I was trying to
get here's some other background how do
you make how do you get a car to fit
within the cafe laws you make it lighter
but when you make it lighter it becomes
less safe an economist at Harvard and
Brookings Institution found that the
cafe laws and the amount of model year
89 would cause about 2,000 extra deaths
a year in other words two-thirds of a
World Trade Center every year and I was
basically trying to get Ralph Nader to
admit than the trade-off between
regulation and safety he chosen
regulation and he wasn't gonna go there
but it was fun trying and in a way his
associate Clarence Ditlow of the Center
for auto safety did go there he said
you're never going to get me to admit
that but it's kind of like admitting it
where was I going with that oh yeah
unintended consequences there's one
major unintended consequence of
something that Congress is about to pass
I don't follow it day to day because
they're doing so much you cannot follow
it day to day by the way they can't
follow it day to day most of the people
who voted for the USA PATRIOT Act did
not read it yes yes so I'm not sure if
this one is passed I believe it is not
passed but it's close and that is
legislation that would essentially
subsidize insurance against terrorism
now in economics and the economics of
insurance there's something called moral
hazard moral hazard is this when you
have insurance in other words when the
downside of your act
is somewhat covered you have less
incentive to avoid the downside moral
hazard is thought of as a negative
if moral hazard is big enough insurance
won't exist because it won't be worth it
so for example you get life insurance
you're more likely to do risky
activities after you've gotten life
insurance because you're covered
well it's interesting to look at the
arguments that are being made for
subsidies of terror anti-terrorism
insurance the main argument made is that
there will be moral hazard why do I say
that well the people who are pushing it
are saying if this terrorism insurance
isn't subsidized either insurance
companies aren't going to offer it or
they're gonna price it high if they
price it high people are not going to
have an incentive to build in the
high-risk areas and economic activity is
going to disperse so we want to prevent
economic activity from dispersing it's
like saying as we do with the we have
flood insurance we have the federal
government's fund flood insurance it's
like saying we want people to locate on
flood plains by the way the federal
government is acting is if we do want
people to locate in flood plains it's
highly subsidized and that's why we get
this destruction now one of the there's
just a lot of little things you hear
through your life and you kind of go
along with them you don't really think
about them I think one of the neat
things about economics is if it's done
right it gets you thinking about him and
let me quote one from a senator from
Minnesota named I keep blanking his name
West Weston well stuff about a year and
a half ago he said something he said
words like the following about the
pharmaceutical companies they want to
make money off people sickness and
he said it with a you know negative
connotation now it got me thinking I
realized you know he's right they do
want to make money off people's sickness
just as food companies want to make
money off people's hunger but food
companies don't try to make money by
making us more hungry they try to make
money by feeding us
similarly drug companies don't try to
make money by making a sicker they try
to make money by making us more well six
years ago I had an incident where I
started to lose bodily fluids and I lost
10 pounds in 24 hours and I was so
delirious I couldn't even make a
decision about what to do and my wife
decided to send me to the hospital so I
went to the hospital and it's a
community hospital the Monterey
Peninsula we locals call it chomp and
they put me in this beautiful white bed
and they pump these fluids in my armas
to remember how cold it felt and I slept
for 22 out of the next 24 hours when my
wife and daughter came to visit me in
the morning I didn't even know they were
there and my doctor later told me that
they saved my life that if I hadn't gone
in my my body would have been destroyed
and it had already gone the part where
he said every cell in my body was
damaged it took me weeks to recover
think about that when I and by the way I
did think about it I think about these
things and not just how am I ever glad
my life was saved but thinking more
about the economics of it too because
the people who saved my life were people
I didn't even know they were strangers
and yet they gave their best effort or
at least good enough effort to save me
and for the next few months after that
when I would drive by chomp if I had a
passenger in my car with me I'd cheer
and if I didn't have a passenger I'd
blow a kiss that's how happy I felt
about them I wanted them to make money
off my sickness see I'm 51 and I don't
want to get Parkinson's and I don't want
to get Alzheimer's and I don't want to
get what was that other one
I don't want to get cancer or if I get
him I want them to be low not that bad
and and I might not get them but I don't
want my friends to get them either and
this is the really neat thing about
capitalism and free markets that there
are people out there in the world whom I
don't know whom I'll never know who are
spending their time up late at night
trying to figure out ways to make me
well they don't know about me they don't
care about me if they met me they might
not even like me
and yet they are doing this now this is
essentially the the I called the Adam
Smith eyepencil insight to stories Adam
Smith everyone's heard of him he once
said and one of the most famous line of
the book it is not from the benevolence
of the brewer the butcher of the Baker
that we expect our dinner but from their
regard for their own self-interest in
other words they aren't doing it to be
nice guys to us but they find the way to
do well for themselves is to be nice
guys to us by producing the goods well
similarly there's a famous man named
Leonard Reed who wrote an article to
classic article in 1958 called I pencil
in which he holds up I got a I pin the
best I can do he holds it helped Milton
Friedman drew on this in his free to
choose stirs it's the pencil talking and
the pencil says no one knows how to make
me it's a literally true statement that
no one knows how to make me well then
how do I get made well because each
individual you know in a division of
labor of millions of individuals knows
one little piece of it no one even knows
how to make the wood in me that's an
incredible division of labor no one
knows how to make the lid that's an
incredible incredible division later and
it's brought together all in one if we
were to try to do it on our own we would
fail and there's this but the thing is
the market leads to this division of
labor were there people all over the
world working together coordinating the
price system coordinates them without
any central planner and as a result you
get this pencil that costs a couple of
pennies to produce and think about that
if you try to Bruce on your own you can
spend
a year and you would not have as good a
pencil as you can get for about ten
cents of the store that's incredible
and when I was a kid I used to I lived
in I grew up in a small town in
Midwestern Canada when we go into the
city the first few times I could the
city of Winnipeg half a million
population I would worry a little I mean
I knew pretty much everyone in my town
but I didn't know these people these
strangers in the city well gee I get
there and I want to get something who
will do it for me how will I get how why
will they be nice to me they don't even
know me and bit by bit I understood the
market that they had incentives to be
nice to me and that if fat I got admits
even now when I travelled a place like
New York you know the little hick and me
comes out and I get all worried about
you know how will they treat me and of
course people in New York are wonderful
and the market works on that issue I
just want to point out that there's an
economist who just really nailed this
issue some years ago and his name was
Joseph Schumpeter about the incredible
productivity of the market and he I
quoted this in my chapter the joy of
capitalism he pointed out that the
virtue of capitalism is not he says he
says Queen Elizabeth had silk stockings
the virtue of capitalism is not that
rich people get silk stockings the
virtue of capitalism is that poor people
get silk stockings or get nylons or get
whatever after the rich people have had
a few years and it's really interesting
just to look back there are two kinds of
comparisons to make one is with 300
years ago and now and what I always like
to do is think about travel think about
when you travel 300 years ago the only
the only two groups really traveled the
really rich people who had a horrible
time of it they had to you know be in
the elements the cold the heat and so on
without air-conditioning without warmth
and the really poor people who were
drafted and sent off to the Crusades
that was it
now we can travel halfway around the
world for what in America is less than a
half of an average person's monthly
salary and we can do it in about seven
to fifteen hours and our idea of a tough
trip is that or our knees were cramped
and the person beside is talked too much
and we got a little dry that's our idea
of a tough trip capitalism is that great
capitalism is that productive eat but
you can make comparisons even with much
shorter time periods I think I'm
fifty-one when I was 10 years old we
spent Christmas with a family and their
precocious five-year-old daughter had a
crush on me so chased me around the
house until my pants split we were a
half a block from home so I went home
and changed pants came back she chased
me again buy pants split I was out of
options I had two pairs of pants I had
one pair of shoes and I wasn't from some
poor family I was from just like family
the income below the median in Canada
which is only a little below the median
the United States at the time that's the
way things were think now we're I have a
friend who makes $15,000 a year and he
showed me his closet one day and he's
got these beautiful sweaters and shirts
and pants got a lot of them at Goodwill
but isn't that interesting that Goodwill
sells these things really nice things
cheap now I've kind of talked a lot
about markets and how markets work and I
haven't really talked about government
except that one case with postal Express
I want to say a few things about
government and then I want to say a few
things about civil liberties if I can
get there I have a chapter in this book
titled a tour of Washington I had two
tours in Washington in a sense I was a
summer intern in the White House when
that meant something a little different
one difference was I was paid and at the
Council of Economic Advisers as a matter
of fact and I remember my first day in
Washington
I flew overnight through Atlanta on the
cheap Delta line airline out of LA to
Washington I got out of the cab it was I
hadn't slept at all on that flight I got
out of a cab at the old executive office
building and I looked and there over the
old executive office building was a huge
Soviet flag and I just had little enough
sleep that for a split second I thought
oh my god they took over overnight and
then I saw people kind of walking
normally along the street and then the
thought was a invasion of the body
snatchers no no no so I went to the all
executive office building and checked in
and while I'm waiting to be allowed in
past the Secret Service I asked one of
the Secret Service guys you know about
why the Soviet flag is there and he says
oh coz Brezhnev is in town and we're
doing it as a courtesy and I thought wow
Brezhnev represents the most murderous
regime murderous regime in history and
in fact they haven't admitted even that
they've murdered let alone apologized
for it and we're putting up his flag I
wondered what other tyrant might come to
town whose flag we put up I didn't have
to wait long that summer the green flag
from Iran was off as the shop isn't it
and as I went through the day I noticed
that people when I'd asked secretaries
senior economists anyone about this they
didn't seem at all surprised they say it
was just normal course but this is what
you do which maybe go back to the body
snatchers again and and I realized that
Washington was going to be a strange
place and that was the that was the
summer of price controls when the price
controls were causing all these
shortages and I have a number of stories
about that in the book about how I tried
successfully to avoid working in favor
of the price controls and then I went
back again in the early 80s as a senior
economist of the same place Council of
Economic Advisers and I had other
experiences there but when I started
that summer with an unsettling thought
but I am an empiricist it's one reason
by the way I've never been an Austrian
economist a story David they're not they
aren't nearly empirical enough for me
and and I always like to look at the
facts and not just go with a priority
not just go you know not just theory but
look at some facts and so I didn't start
out being positive of this but I was
wondering this I was wondering does
government care about us does the
government do government officials in
their day-to-day activities really care
about us and I was starting to think
they don't that's what I was starting to
think based on things I've read at the
start of the summer by the end of the
summer I was had an even higher
probability on the idea that they don't
and then I went back there in the 80s
for about two and a half years and came
out positive that they don't and I have
a type that my chapters taught of a tour
of Washington and and the analogy here's
the analogy that I have with with
Washington with government generally
it's a movie that they keep showing
endlessly in American movie classics
called the getaway with Ali MacGraw and
Steve McQueen where they're bad guys but
they aren't quite as bad as the other
bad guys and there's fighting over the
loot and in they're fighting over the
loot they're they're destroying lots of
property held by innocent people I would
guess $50,000 worth of property at least
an elevator a bunch of cars etc and they
don't care about the property they're
destroying and about the third time I
saw that an AMC one night I thought you
know what that's the government the
government does things because it's
pursuing very narrow ends the government
officials are pursuing their hands and
they don't care about what would we call
collateral damage good example steel
quotas economists have estimated that
steel quotas designed to save us jobs
cost the US economy cost the US consumer
750,000 dollars a year per job saved
that's a year per job saved and a job is
a $40,000 job why because they are
focusing on the interest group that
wants those jobs they don't care about
consumers whose interests are dispersed
and don't even aren't even aware of the
cost to them and yes their biome off
instead and so that kind of for me
stands for a lot of what government does
government we we hear that government
has incentives to take account of
everything but in fact it's just the
opposite
markets if things are privately-owned
markets take account of everything
because someone has everything at each
individual thing at risk but if
governments are making decisions and
they don't have to pay the consequences
they don't take account of everything
and fat they don't take kind of much and
there are many examples like this and
actually I this gets me to civil
liberties when I wrote this book I
didn't no no that's not true let me zoom
I wrote an article in red herring of
November 99 I urge you to check my
website www.investmentpitch.com
forthwith it's pet program has its own
narrow ends so for example the FBI comes
up with carnivore which by the way they
had come up with some years ago and they
aren't just gonna use it to go after
terrorists they're gonna use to go after
lots of people including maybe people in
this audience maybe people watching it
on TV
the Office of Homeland Security
basically was set up based on a draft
that have been created over the last few
years the new regulations on financial
financial regulations where the
government is going to know even more
about your bank account were regulations
that were rejected because of a massive
writing campaign a couple of years ago
it's called know your customer and they
were
down like crazy and now they're back
they're in and so these various people
these various players had their own
narrow ends they were trying to achieve
here was a crisis there was a great
excuse to do it now
am i sympathetic with the idea of maybe
on the margin cutting back on some civil
liberties in order to go after specific
cases of terrorism I am not in the sense
I favor him in the sense I'm willing to
look at him but that's not what's going
on what's going on is wholesale massive
reductions in civil liberties with no
focus going after lots of people that
has nothing to do with terrorism by the
way one of the things defined in the USA
PATRIOT Act is domestic terrorism by the
way the the attack on September 11th
broke three different terrorist laws in
other words we already have laws in the
books that they broke and of course they
murdered but the domestic terrorism
includes threatening government
officials it also includes harboring
people who might have committed some
kind of violence now I'm not someone who
believes in violence but let's say my
daughter who turned 17 yesterday becomes
a Marxist in two years perish the
thought but let's say she does and she
becomes one of these anti global people
who wants to keep people in third world
starving I hope she doesn't but let's
say she does and she goes to an IMF
conference and she hits a cop or
something and then she comes home and
lives with me I'm harboring a domestic
terrorist that and that's that's a
serious crime so the government is
actually going to put people in the
position of being criminals who'd never
thought they'd be criminals for the
standard normal everyday things they're
doing that's the kind of thing that's
going on now when should i I want to
wrap up I don't want to I got on the
five minutes okay
I want to go to a heavy topic but with a
little light note for a minute
I have a chapter in here titled maybe we
can't and death but let's take a shot at
taxes and there's a great stand and I
kind of I like starting off as you'll
see if you read the book I like starting
off a lot of these chapters with my own
story and then going to other people's
stories and I remember just the shock
when I was 16 and I went up or I was 18
I went to a city in northern Canada and
got a job in the summer working in mind
and make money to pay for my last year
of college and hadn't filled out the
form riotous I had all this money
withheld and then I had to beg them with
a the equivalent of a 1040 form to get
it back and I couldn't fill it out I
because I was begging the government I
could not make myself fill it out so I
had to get my brother to do it for me
I signed it and I was reminded of that
when I read a news article about Venus
Williams in September 2000 mr. Williams
had just won the US Open at the tender
age of 19 it received a check for
$800,000 President Clinton called to
congratulate her and miss Williams
recounted that conversation to an LA
Times reporter he this is her talking he
said you really worked hard I said see I
did work hard and I want to keep this
for me I'm a good citizen can you lower
my taxes please this is me talking
Clinton then had the gall to say there
wasn't much he could do about it
although maybe he could go out and get a
lower rate for athletes wasn't much he
could do about it that's not what he
thought in 1993 when the tax increased
he proposed sign and bragged about was
implemented a tax increase the cosmas
was more than 80,000 for $800,000 win
the president can do a lot about taxes
if he had decided to seek repeal this is
93 tax increase he would have had enough
Republican votes that was the summer of
2000 to pull it off and he could have
cut taxes retroactively Lee also just as
he imposed them retroactively Lee I know
this may sound shocking but President
Clinton lied
maybe mr. Williams knew some of this
history and maybe that's why she went
under on to ask him whether he was
asking her to read his lips now the last
chapter of my book is titled freedom in
our time and I lead it off with a one of
my favorite quotes Tamara startled the
philosophy that can't help you do things
does nothing so the whole point of this
is to do something and I lay out a
number of things you can do and I won't
don't want to just dwell on I want to
just mention a couple things one is to
be creative too I'll give you an example
my mother died of cancer
my wife had cancer she's alive and well
and I give to the American Cancer
Society
but what I've been thinking about lately
is there's probably an even more
effective way to fight cancer and that
is to fight the regulations and drug
companies because the people who are
gonna solve cancer are not likely to be
the American Cancer Society wonderful as
those people are the people are gonna
fight cancer are the people who are
gonna make a lot of money doing it and I
want them to do it quickly which means I
want the FDA to deregulate and I lay out
in my health chapter how that can be
done with everyone being better off and
I owe some of that reasoning to my
friend Charlie Hooper's in the audience
who's a consultant of drug companies so
there's one so I remember one time when
my father wanted gives some money in my
name to an old folks in my name and my
mother's name to an old folks home and
in my name I had him give it to an
organization in Washington instead that
was fighting laws against theirs
fighting to relax laws against drugs
also there's one thing we can do that I
think people underestimate that I think
is really important and that is speak
out the number of times I run into
people Milton Friedman tells a story in
his book and his and his wife's book two
lucky people about how over the years
people have said to him
gee mr. Friedman professor Friedman you
are so courageous to say those things
and he said you know I never felt
courageous and when I looked at the
consequences I never saw any really bad
consequence
from speaking my mind people just
imagine that all these bad consequences
speaking their mind and if they're
pleasant about it and if they actually
and by the way important thing is to
listen to what the other person says
back do not just speechify then there's
very little to lose and so I give a few
examples of things that one might do
when when people and I can't find it
here
well I'll just wait when someone says
let's raise taxes ask them if you can
have their wallet you know when a male
says let's prevent gays from getting
married ask them if they would have
liked a government to prevent them from
getting married to their spouse if
someone says let's regulate drug
companies ask them if they want their
children to have a better chance or
worse chance of surviving in life
there's a lot of things we can do and we
just have to be a little creative about
it I also think we should thank people
who do little things for freedom and I
gave an example I spoke in an event a
few years ago which one of the other
speakers was Charles Stan home a
Democratic congressman from Texas I
remembered that almost 20 years earlier
his crossover vote had been important in
getting Ronald Reagan's package of
budget cuts they were small but they
were real and tax cuts approved so I
thanked him did that man look surprised
I don't think congressmen are used to
getting thanked at all let alone for a
vote they had 20 years ago
and I want to end with one of my
favorite quotes about famous by a famous
libertarian about the most libertarian
the most Pro freedom fight in our
nation's history and that was the fight
against slavery and the libertarian was
Frederick Douglass and he said the
following if there's no struggle there
is no progress those who perhaps profess
to favor freedom and yet deprecated
agitation are men who men who want crops
without plowing up the ground they want
rain without thunder and lightning they
want the ocean without the mighty roar
of its awful waters this struggle may be
a moral one or it may be a physical one
and it may be both moral and physical
but it must be a struggle power concedes
nothing without a demand it never did
and it never
we'll find out just what any people will
quietly submit to and you have found out
the exact measure of injustice and wrong
which will be imposed upon them and
these will continue until they are
resisted with either words or blows or
both the limits of tyrants are
prescribed by the endurance of those
whom they oppress so let's stop settling
let's speak out when our freedom is
violated and even better let's do the
same when the freedom of others is
violated it's not too late to seek a
freer world
thank you David we have time for
questions
carl has a microphone and if you'd hold
it horizontally win and speak make your
questions short if you can the Secretary
of Health tommy thompson assented model
an emergency health care act to all the
states asking the governor the state
legislators to pass an act that would
allow the governor by Fiat to take over
the entire healthcare of his state upon
his decision yes and no one could
interfere with that decision in less
than 60 days when the legislature could
vote it out if you're not aware of this
existence one should look into it
because there are penalties and possibly
jail terms for those that let's say
won't allow themselves to be vaccinated
or a doctor who won't do a vaccination
be aware look into it it's draconian yes
I was just reading about the other day
and one of the other provisions is it
would actually allow the government to
draft doctors to draft doctors
so much of what you said is is very
agreeable it seems to me and reciprocity
as a device for producing
accountabilities and very very necessary
but what you did it seemed to me was to
denigrate government and what it really
does produce and it seemed to me there's
some cheap shots every good well we can
travel seven and the Sun so comfortably
all of us is that we do have some
protection against Marauders and pirates
and so forth of the only Kings had in
the old days
so government does some things will and
it does some things badly and there is
almost an invisible hand that works in
government the way it works in the
marketplace after all what you said was
that business people really don't care
about the people that they're helping
and assisting but there is a this kind
of unintended consequence that it does
help in government in the same way does
especially because of the the fact that
we have two houses of Congress or two
houses everyplace else
we have appeals we have tons of people
participating we have an open open
market of ideas and the result is that
all those horrible examples that you
were throwing out probably aren't going
to be passed into law and the few that
get through are probably gonna be
knocked down by courts you know I was
going along with a lot of what you were
saying the government does provide
protection and by the way I I'm an
agnostic in this I don't know how good a
job it does I do note that we did pay
three hundred billion dollars a year and
we thought we were getting a homeland
defense and it turns out we weren't but
but it does provide protection
I think the oceans do an awfully good
job attitude that's a major factor in
our protection from foreign invaders but
but no the fact is a lot of these laws
do get through and they become part of
what we accept as a given and in fact
Robert Higgs whom David mentioned
earlier in his book this really good
book I reviewed this for Fortune in 1987
it's one of my favorite books of the 80s
he points out that during war government
takes on crisis powers and loses some of
them after the war but never goes back
and as for example one example he gives
or it goes back with a long lag and in
this case is prohibition we think of
prohibition starting in nineteen
in 1920 turnout has started during the
war because of price controls price
controls kept the price of grain
artificially low so it caused a shortage
of grain it was hard to justify
allocating limited grain to people who
are going to distill it into whiskey and
so the government refused to allow it to
be made in into alcohol and we got under
I think was called the lever act we got
prohibition during the war and that
softened up the American people that was
easy to accept it back then in 1920 the
draft was introduced during the World
War one it was eliminated at the end but
then it was introduced in 1940 it was
eliminated for only one year 1948 and
then we had it until 1973 so the reality
is that we we lose freedoms and we get
only some of them back I'll give another
example taxation before in the world
World War two there was no withholding
of taxes you paid it every quarter and
you probably didn't pay it or your
counterparts didn't pay it because it
was the class tax it was it was taxed it
was on the highest income people the
government lowered the threshold of
which to tax people during World War Two
and introduced withholding to make him
pay it on the installment plan and never
got rid of withholding and from then on
taxed a large percent of the American
people restrictions on freedom of speech
most of those go away but but not all of
them so no I I disagree I mean look
we've got division of powers we've got
two houses we've got I love that but
what this president is doing is trying
to get rid of that he's trying by
executive order and other things to get
rid of that and that's very dangerous
and Congress is letting him in a lot of
these things Congress still hasn't heard
that in the Constitution it's supposed
to decide whether or war and inste
weekly it's alleged that World War
butwe that the Congress has not declared
war and so there's one that went away
sometime in the last century and we've
never got back we've never had that
division of powers
my question involves the rent control
which we have in Auckland here and it's
been growing every few months in
incremental steps but it seems to me
that the people that are really
benefitting from our rent control are
very often the people who know how to
take care of government take advantage
of government regulations very bright
young yuppies people that are hurting
right now are especially the minorities
and those of lower economic status
I wonder if you could comment on that
and explain why economists so rarely get
involved in the debate on rent control
when there must be a lot of them in
Berkeley in Oakland yeah okay thanks
Garrett I think that that's I think
you've laid out the facts right and let
me give a couple examples from New York
which I'm more familiar with and Edie
Koch had an apartment I don't know if he
still has to be in a beautiful apartment
for 200 some dollars a month in
Manhattan Mia Farrow
similarly had a nice apartment well
under the the market rent and so it is
people who know the rules better who get
to take advantage of this losers are the
losers are people who are new to the
area it's hard to move into a place like
that and for example in in Prague
they've got heavy rent controls and
that's why that's limiting the growth of
the Czech economy unemployment rate is
in Prague is 2% the unemployment rate in
Czech Republic is a multiple of that but
people can't move there and by the way
the property owners are badly hurt it's
a myth by the way that all property
owners are wealthy I wrote something in
rent control and I used to live in the
Bay Area in 1979 and the San Francisco
Chronicle and a group of property owners
and Berkeley invited me to speak and I
showed up you know wearing my suit and
this and that and a Saturday morning and
they showed up wearing blue jeans and
but it wasn't like the yuppies wearing
blue jeans it was kind of working-class
people and for many of them they owned
one or two units that was they had
planned to be their retirement and and
that was just our opening to me now why
economists not get involved
there's a long answer and I'll try to
give the short one economist by the way
if you get an Apple taken of economists
in the late 1970s 98 percent agreed and
this was out of 211 economist 98% that
rank controlled destroys housing it's
not controversy within economics so if
you could get economists involved they
would say that the problem is economics
has gone far away from having much to do
with public policy or with communicating
with the public if you go to an
economics department nowadays in the
United States almost invariably you will
find courses you'll find reading lists
that don't seem to be about anything
that would matter to you
and I remember running into a reporter
in the Bay Area some years ago who had
been through the Stanford program and he
dropped out and I said why did you drop
out of the graduate program in economics
of Stanford he said well when I got to
the second course of an industrial
organization class and was just proof
lemma proof lemma and we hadn't yet
heard the word the firm I thought
there's something wrong here
so it Kannamma 'kz is is more and more
about kind of how many angels dance on
the head of a pin and less and less
about the real world now if you can get
a con economist to let his hair down
you'll hear some very sensible things
and in my fortune cyclope of economics
that was my goal I was noticing this
real coalescence among a lot around a
lot of issues but it wasn't coming out
to the public and I want to do that so I
got economists who could write and I
found a whole lot of them but but if you
look at what is taught and graduate
economics programs today it isn't very
useful there's a great chapter on rent
control laying it out from the start of
it again started during wartime in
Europe and in the United States and I've
also very frustrating personal stories
with it both as a renter and as a
property owner in Cambridge
Massachusetts and also here in San
Francisco it's amazing it still exists
and it's Berkeley
the color-line to answer the gentleman's
question over there was talking about
maybe the legitimate role as the
government sometimes that even gets
skewed because recently somebody asked a
question to the Swiss who pay a large
amount in in defense as a percentage the
budget said why do you continue to pay
these huge defense expenditures when you
haven't been invaded in 300 years but
nobody he didn't understand it 300 years
because they have a standing army that
trains continuously plan but that's his
point okay and everybody has a gun at
home since taxes tend to discourage what
this tax number of groups have focused
on the idea of say taxing pollution as a
way of reducing pollution and Milton
Friedman has also said that the least
bad taxes the tax on the fair value of
land I wonder if you could comment on is
there granted that many of the things
that we do tax are awful right if you
can comment on whether whether there is
any such thing as a good tax and to the
extent that we should have government
how should it be funded okay good
question
there are about three issues you raised
because the one about taxing pollution I
used to be actually an advocate of
taxing pollution but the more I've read
about the more I've thought about it and
the more I've just learned about some
history and I have a I have an R a
chapter in here I didn't get to tonight
titled the environment own it and save
it that the key to having the
environment treated well is to have it
just to have someone own it and the
second best but it's a distant second
best is to tax pollution and if you
start thinking through the problems with
taxing pollution it's it's just it
doesn't work well it's you don't know
what level to set people's rights can
still be violated because they're still
being polluted I'll give you one little
story in Ohio there was a famous
incident in the 1960s where the Cuyahoga
River that goes through Cleveland
fire well it turned out because of all
the pollution it turned out that wasn't
the first time the first time was the
early 1950s something interesting
happened in the late 1940s the Ohio
common law was moving to allow people on
the river to sue people upriver who
polluted and it was working people were
actually stopping to pollute and and it
was it was working the legislature got
together in 1948 and overturned that and
said we want to give people we want to
give permits to pollute and we'll decide
who against the permit so they chose
what are the industrial rivers in other
words what are the sinks you know it's
worth of the pollution and we'll let
we'll get people liberal permits to
prove to pollute there and that's what
led to it so so what didn't get tried
very much but to the extent it did get
tried was starting to work with property
rights and that's my first preference
would be property rights Friedman did
say once that the the least bad tax is a
tax on on sight values not not
improvements on land because then that
will discourage improvements but the
sight value of the land and he's right
that is the least bad tax right I don't
I don't yeah Henry George they're not
live Yeah right
Lloyd George taxed everything so so yeah
there is a point to that now here's the
thing in my ideal society I actually
think we might need taxes and I don't
like that because I do think taxation is
theft but I think we might need a
certain amount of theft and I hate to
say it that way but I think we need
taxes to be for every level of
government
a total of under 3 percent of GNP and so
if they're under 3 percent of GNP you
really have to mess up badly to have
really damaging taxes they aren't going
to be if it's on income if it's on
property if it's a sales tax matters but
what matters more is the I want it to be
a lot lower so take any tax that exists
today and I think it's too high
well that's bad too
he's been waiting a long time as a 911
the world trade center notably one of
the symbols of capitalism in the world
was attacked
what can capitalists do to strike back
yeah well first I want to point out was
a government building it was built by a
government the Port Authority of New
York because Rockefeller wanted to
unload some land and he found a
government agency willing to buy it so
that's just important part of history
there right yeah I think that's right
that's right what's his name leased it
but it was a silver burger Lisa okay
what can they do to strike back
strike back whom I gotta get clarity
just strike first of all nineteen people
are covered right nineteen people who
murdered are taken care of so then the
question is who else is there who's
involved in it and and I think that's
something we should find out now what
are the best ways to do that there is
this part of the Constitution called
letters of marque and reprisal it is
it's something when you talk to an
informed audience and they know more
than you do about a lot of these things
so I'm just kind of mouthed but you'll
get the words exactly right and it is
very clever Jefferson used I guess to go
after some pirates and the idea is to
give private people incentives to go
after the bad guys and and now it is
gonna be hard to know who are the bad
guys but I can tell you who aren't the
bad guys it's the year and a one and a
half year old who got killed the other
day when the when the roof of our house
collapsed in Afghanistan it's a whole
lot of people who lost their families
those aren't the bad guys and so I mean
it you have to go after the bad guys I
don't think you throw out all the rules
and just say they killed a whole bunch
of our innocent people therefore we
should kill a whole bunch of their
innocent people
he's been waiting
yeah you know when you bring up these
issues you you think about history
politics economics debates going back to
Hamilton and Jefferson so Jefferson but
they when Jefferson bought the Louisiana
Purchase yeah the Federalists were
violently opposed they use tax money to
pay for it so well if you were on the
Council of Economic Advisors then what
would you said dr. Henderson don't see
the thing is one of the things that
protects us and actually here's where
the invisible hand works I want to go
back to something you said that I wanted
to amplify that this man in front said
that one of the things that protects us
is competition among governments the
more the more competition you have among
governments the less they can tax us the
less they can regulate us so I believe
in having as little government as
possible the federal level and have it
down as low as possible so I would have
rather obscene frankly the thirteen
colonies they and and they were by the
way they had their 13 governments the 13
states had their 13 governments and not
a strong federal government and I was
Jefferson and I were together in that
one and then Louisiana Purchase just not
have it and have some other government
or some some other political affiliation
I wrote an article in The Wall Street
Journal few years ago as I said I'm from
Canada laying out why most Canadians
would be better off if Quebec were
allowed to secede and I think that's
right you'd have more competition and I
think I think we would not have America
throwing its weight around in the world
the way it is if there weren't an
America in other words if there were say
ten governments instead of one or five
or three or 50 and and I think that
would be preferable and by the way for
that reason I'm not in favor of what's
going on in the European Union I think
that we're gonna get this massive
government over there
I just like to comment on what a pilot
told me the other day I was asking about
security and the airplanes and he was
suggesting that September 11 could not
have happened except for the fact that
we didn't give our pilots freedom
instead we gave them a policy that said
if you ever have a hijacker you have to
go along with with every says yeah and
he said the simple fact of changing that
policy will make all the difference in
the world much more than all the
billions were spending on extra security
yeah so sometimes ideas of freedom
actually give us more security yeah and
I want to just amplify on that and one
of the my big heroes and I talking about
benefit in my book is Friedrich Hayek
and I had an article in The Wall Street
Journal in October when the Nobel prizes
were awarded because they were all given
to people who worked on information and
I point out although you could argue
that two out of three of them deserved
the Nobel Prize they did work on
asymmetric information but I think they
missed the most important asymmetry and
the most important asymmetry information
is between decentralized information
held by participants in the market and
centralized information held by
government look back in September 11th
and think about the one thing that went
right on that horrible day it was flight
93 it was people with their cell phones
responding in a decentralized way to
decentralized information they knew what
would happen if they didn't take over
the plane and that changed that as you
said that changed at all that shape that
suddenly the stakes were different and
so if we if the government had done
nothing on airport security after
September 11th we would have been safer
than we were than than than before now
in fact they could have even gone
further and that is deregulated let that
be an issue for the airlines to choose
did they allow pilots to carry guns or
not there was a hijack attempted
hijacking in the 1950s that a pilot a
pilot shot the hijacker dead in the
United States and ended the hijacking
so those those are options and now I
don't think that I'm not saying the
federal government should require that
airlines let their pilot have their
pilot's carry guns I say airlines have
strong incentives to make good decisions
about that let them choose and there'll
be different choices I want to point out
one other thing what I was watching
c-span the other day and it's unbiased
they won one senator was saying we've
got to have uniform standards at
airports for security I thought does
this guy ever play poker uniform
standards which means once you figure
them out you know how to do it anywhere
what you want is changing standards that
aren't predictable and that's what we
would get with private airports with
private Airlines and so on okay the last
question you sort of danced around this
I didn't plan to one of the things he
talked about was the ability to travel
the other day I heard a statistic I
don't know if it's accurate that less
than 5% of the population in this
country has a passport and one of the
things that has profoundly affected me
of my life is the ability to travel and
I think you're right about our oceans
and the size of our country and you go
to Europe and you forget for what US is
a state as a country yeah and you're
constantly crossing through borders and
it's a totally different sense of
government and I also had the fortune of
being in Germany when East Germany still
existed and I saw that border and that
has ultimately very much affected my
thoughts on government and what I do and
then taking this back to the fact that
people in this country haven't had a lot
of exposure and have a very my mind
sanitized and liberalized media how does
capitalism come into effect in terms of
educating people more you know
see we don't see any kind ballistic news
you know happening and I guess not
ballistic what you don't see you don't
see a station yet that has been really
being crew okay Terry you know you don't
see these coming up yeah
and I guess my last comment in terms of
yours on the Louisiana Purchase is and
having more governments is do you ever
think of it would be a viable third
party okay I think that it's it does
help clearly to have competition in the
media but the major competition is not
Fox as I heard a few people saying the
major competition is the internet most
of my information now I don't I haven't
watched the the network news in a few
decades as a rake I mean I watch it once
in a while but I used to watch it
regular I don't haven't watched it
regularly in a few decades and most of
my information now I get off the web I
find out what they're saying in London
newspapers I read something on The Times
of India this morning all these things
and it's wonderful you really and by the
way I highly recommend that you read
what people in other countries are
writing about us it's very eye-opening I
have a chapter in this book again I
didn't talk about it it's on education
in which I lay out the problems with
government schooling so-called public
schools and I think that the major
reform that could make all the
difference in the world would be to get
the government out of schools and I lay
out kind of the Prussian I lay out the
Prussian roots of our government
schooling how is actually intended to
propagandize and it's succeeding and and
it was intended to make it hard to read
and it's succeeding and I actually tell
that story in there and so so I think
that would be the major change and I
have some hope about that homeschooling
is growing and you'll have some hope now
your last thing about third party I
don't know see what's happened is that
the two major parties have carefully
colluded using campaign finance laws to
do what monopolist do or duopoly
do and that is to try to rig the rules
against outsiders and so it's very hard
now to compete as a third party and I
don't I just don't know whether whether
third parties will will be viable but by
the way they couldn't it's the good news
is they would not ever have to be viable
in the sense of winning elections to be
effective and I want to tell a story
that my friend Jill Furyk in the
audience told recently in a speech that
I new part of and I didn't know the last
part of a man named Norman Thomas ran
for president starting I think in around
1928 and in 1932 he ran and Roosevelt
won against Hoover Roosevelt's platform
called for diminishing the size of
government cutting taxes cutting
government spending cutting government
employment he broke all his promises a
book came out in 1936 laying out a
platform and saying look at all these
things this platform calls for and look
at all the things Roosevelt did and
Roosevelt had done what the platform
called for he said one little problem
the platform was Norman Thomas's
socialist party platform Roosevelt had
implemented it well Norman Thomas ran
again and again and again never won a
state never won a huge percent of the
vote but in 1956 he decided not to run
that was when Stevenson was a yes
Stevenson and rising high rent were
running Eisenhower was running for a
second term he is not not to run and the
media who liked him because he was a
colorful character to follow asked him
why and he said well the Republican
Party is accepted everything I ran on in
1928 so see the way you can have an
impact as a third party is by doing what
what you should do I mean take the
positions you should take and let the
other parties follow so for example in
the drug war call for the end of the
drug war and then the other parties will
move around the edges towards that
position
that's what Ralph Nader did with the
Green Party to some extent talked about
the end of the drug war and that are at
least diminishing it and Harry Brown
called for the outright end of the drug
war if the Libertarian Party and said
that if he were elected he would pardon
every nonviolent drug criminal in prison
which would have by the way solved our
prison problem
policies I want to thank David for his
talk and if you join with me and it's
not just that this is really a great
book but David is a very good writer so
if you enjoy a good read and you can
learn a lot from how they recommend it
again for those of you have not gotten
copies there are copies upstairs still
and I'm sure he'd be happy to autograph
them for you thank you all for coming
and making this a very successful
evening for us and we look forward to
seeing you at our next independent
Institute of that good night